oh I do remember this oh why are you
doing this to me well I just I'm looking
at that girl and I want to give her a
hug hi I'm Megan Fox and they are gonna
force me to watch all of my old movie
clips and interviews I just got sick to
my stomach okay
it's coming oh excuse me Oh were you in
line Brianna Wallace messages please die
and how is your father today in the
casino wondering why this is taking so
long uh kill me just kill me why are you
doing this to me just smother me or
something
my assistant is a 25 year old girl and
she sends me gifts of myself all the
time and one of them is Brianna Wallace
I think was my character's name so I get
that gift sent to me more often that I
would like I get what I want and this
winter break I want Jordan I don't need
to ever see it again but look at what
they've gone on to do I mean that's
amazing what they've done creating those
fashion brands icons but no I haven't
talked to them since then and that was
what was I 14 so they're almost 20 years
ago crazy
I'm so athletic oh I'm glad you didn't
make me watch the dialogue scenes that
was a weird that was one of the first
things I did it's a shame that these
things survived long enough to see the
dawn of the internet because had it like
it would be nice if they had a click it
it Clips like the internet was born but
these things had sort of fallen away and
no one could find them but here we are I
did an interview I don't remember
oh I do remember that no excuse all made
me listen to myself what am I talking
about
uh that's David that was my first
boyfriend my David Gallagher how are you
I liked him very much very sweet boy
let's talk about David what am I wearing
what is that necklace look away or make
of it so bad I mean what I still talk
like that which is this very thing I
haven't grown up like at all I don't
sound more mature picky about my roles I
don't want to get typecast 15 years
later I didn't even have an agent yet I
don't think actually how long is this
gonna go on this is so long you can't
show this on the show enough look at my
eyebrows you know what she's name
where were my eyebrows I don't know what
I was talking about I guess at that time
though I was already aware of whatever
work I had done up until that point I
was always the mean girl I guess that's
what I was talking about that didn't I
mean I still play those characters often
so it's not like I avoid playing those
characters but um all in all that wasn't
too brutal to watch it was okay I lived
through that one once in that
here's the Thanksgiving we spent with
you unless you oh this is the episode
that Brian was in this is where I met
Brian Hills ooh who's that hot guy
oh is that Brad's Brian is Brian Austin
Green from Beverly Hills 90210 we dated
briefly yeah that was the episode that
Brian was on I met Brian he recently did
an interview and they were saying that I
was 17 and that's not true it was Kelly
and then I think Ted McGinley who was
like who at the table read was like yeah
she's she's 17 so nobody nobody touch
her I was like all right fair enough I
turned 18 in May and not was filmed in
October I remember specifically so I was
already 18 when I met him and yeah I
just was kind of in love with him right
away and he did this thing where he came
to the dressing room and he like gave
his number out to everyone in case
anyone needed to call him at some point
but he gave it was giving it to me like
I knew he was giving me his number and
my sister was with me and she was like
because my sister is older she's 12
years older she actually watched my no
no no I was too young for it and she was
like you're not gonna be anything but a
booty call and this is our tenth year of
marriage and our 15th years together so
you see how that worked out I'm nobody's
booty call okay boy this could go all
kinds of ways yes you got me a tattoo
she's attached where is my school
placement I window that's my love we had
a lot of fun on the first press tour
that's the first time I'd ever done
anything like that
Saten done a junket and they put me with
him thankfully because he's I love him
he's one of my favorite people that I've
ever known and he makes it a lot of fun
and we have a really good chemistry you
can tell like that's how every interview
went I meant I miss
I miss my toilet the movie came out in
86 the series was on in 84 I was born in
86 so I missed the Transformers craze
if I was a big Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles fan who speak and it becomes
real you speak and you manifest it and I
loved those movies and when I booked
that movie I met with the director and
producers and I stayed for five hours on
Valentine's Day to like express how
excited I was to be a part of that and
then when I finally got the call that it
was gonna happen it was going through I
danced I was really excited about it
because I loved I loved a ninja turtles
growing up we made two of them the
second movie we made I really loved and
I'm actually excited to show that to my
kids they're only allowed to watch
movies with us as a family
but I think when the youngest one is old
enough to understand that I'm not being
kidnapped by a ninja that it's all
pretend then I'll probably show them was
I test D I get dusty sometimes okay look
at that that's very exciting and
embarrassing but okay we've got a lot of
guys it kind of obsessive I don't know
why those were always the questions and
I don't know how are you supposed to
answer a question like that you know
there's no real
there's no room eloquent smart way to
answer someone who keeps asking you like
guys are obsessed with you guys like
your body like what what am I supposed
to say thank you oh my god thank you
like I really work out a lot so I'm like
super happy about it I deserve that I'm
not offended if someone were to say hey
people think you're sexy I don't need
there's anything wrong with being sexy
it's just the problem that that part was
so loud that it muted out the rest of
who I was and has continued to even now
I'm 33
so that that was the difficult part
because when I was young I if I was a
cute kid no one told me and I had no
idea and so I always thought if anything
I was really probably pretty ugly and
that was just not a tool I had in my
tool belt I wasn't like oh I'm a pretty
girl and that's something I can use to
my advantage I knew I was smart I knew
that I was funny I knew that I was
strange but in a good way and those are
all things that I thought were my
strengths those were things that's who I
was and then all of a sudden I was none
of those things I was supposed to just
be a sexy girl or the the prettiest
world or the most beautiful which is the
most burdensome title to have to carry
around especially when you don't feel
that way about yourself because you feel
like eventually people are gonna figure
out that this is not true like I know
it's not true right now but the shoes
gonna drop at some point and then what
what am i valued for I'm valued for this
thing which is a farce so it's a
difficult thing to navigate honestly
Megan I know I think I was 23 on that
press tour and I didn't feel like I had
earned any of this I think there s
something a little off with you if you
feel like it's my time and I've really
earned this for me especially I was so
young I had done one movie I didn't
really understand what all of the hype
was about and it's almost like I felt
guilty for it I don't think anyone's
ever prepared for any level of media
attention and scrutiny and and any sort
of loss of anonymity I don't think
there's ever a time when it when it's
the right time
I just I'm looking at that girl and I
want to give her a hug because I
remember what I was going through and it
was such a I was really struggling more
than I was able to express during that
interview for many reasons not just
dealing with Fame in itself there was a
lot going on around that but I mean I
feel the same way I was I have the exact
same mannerisms and my voice sounds the
same and I would probably give an answer
nearly identical to that if you asked me
now which is the surprising part because
I feel like I've grown so much but yet
that I mean I was I guess I've the soul
sort of transcends the time in the space
and I am still the same
experiencing all of these things but I
mean I agree with that answer she was
right
I was right and that wasn't even the
worst part the worst part came out after
that but for me to sit and be resentful
or to really regret something to suffer
because of something that I did in my
past I think is pointless because any
choice that I made I have to accept
responsibility for it and I also have to
acknowledge how it grew me as a person
because there was not one thing that I
went through that was trying or
difficult that didn't help me to grow
into a better individual a smarter
stronger more patient more kind persons
and I also don't believe that I've ever
been a victim she put some reporters in
their places and she's a little
outspoken you know young and brash
Michael Bay was just up here and he said
I'll tell you what I said how's the cast
only up he goes I'll tell you Meghan is
just larger charge she's saying stuff
that is stirring the pot good it's not
my job I'm a professional pot sir yeah
that sort of became the issue to is I
would make jokes and then they would be
headlines as though I was like very
serious proclaiming something it would
be scandalous and so and it just kept it
was like a snowball effect it's just
more and more and more and I just hadn't
learned yet because I was just trying to
be and so I wasn't that cautious because
I felt like all of the thoughtful things
I say should outweigh all of this other
and yet it never did and that's
something that I'm even still I struggle
with because it takes me aback by how
uninterested people are in
the authenticity of an individual in the
entertainment industry but I haven't
been doing a lot of press lately the
last press I can remember doing was when
I was pregnant with my third son and I
was turning 30 I'm 33 now and I was on a
little mini press tour for Ninja Turtles
and every male journalist that came in
was like what plans do you have for your
future because you've always been a sexy
girl but now you're 30 and I remember by
like this second day I was like kind of
yelling at people and I was like I don't
even have wrinkles in my forehead yet
but I'm supposed to hang it up and not
be an actor anymore because I'm 30 q so
for me that was my most recent
experience there was no sort of respect
that had come from the me2 movement and
this whole idea of like we should
respect women and not focus so much on
how they look and that I haven't
experienced yet but that's not to say
that it hasn't happened I just haven't
been doing interviews maybe
when we were shooting it Amanda and I
were making jokes that that was gonna be
the entire trailer it was just gonna be
two minutes the bus sneaking out they
were gonna slow the film and just put it
on blue it was only half the trailer
yeah we both dreaded filming that
because we knew that's what was gonna
happen and for other like the logistics
of filming it also we were both like we
have chin acne we don't want to do this
super-president
but it was also just the concern of like
nobody's going to understand this
nobody's gonna understand the intention
it's going to be turned into this
sensational moment which it was I mean
we all anticipated that so that wasn't a
surprise but it is what it is and now
we're here 10 years later and it's most
most of my fans it's their favorite
project that I've ever done it's my
favorite project that I've ever done I
mean I have some other ones that I
really that I really liked I loved
working on the G Turtles I loved working
on you girl but this one was it it was
just magical at that moment in my life
and it was it was a perfect fit so it's
it's continued to be my favorite nice
all right
[Music]